hi everyone sal khan here from khan
academy welcome to ed talks on khan
academy i know what you're thinking what
are these ed talks well this is kind of
a subset of the homeroom with sal
conversations uh that are are more
focused on education are from experts uh
or specialists in the field of education
we have a really exciting conversation
but before we do that i'm gonna give you
my standard announcements first of all
reminder that we are not for profit we
can only exist through philanthropic
donations from folks like yourself so if
you're in a position to do so please
think about going to khan academy.org
slash donate and any donation amount
makes a huge huge difference i also want
to give a special shout out to many
corporations who've really stepped up
and helped khan academy out during the
covid crisis we were running a deficit
even before the crisis that deficit only
grew as our traffic to our site went to
about 250 percent of normal special
thanks to bank of america google.org att
fastly and novartis
also want to announce that there's a you
can get a version of this and the
homeroom with sal
uh
live streams in homeroom sal the podcast
wherever you might find your podcasts
so with that i am excited to introduce
elisa villanueva beard ceo of teach for
america elisa thanks for coming
hey sal thanks for having me it's good
to be here and um you know
congratulations on all the work that you
all have been leading it's been
inspiring to see how you all have been
meeting the moment and so happy to be
here and in this discussion
and likewise and maybe a good place to
start there's a ton of questions i want
to ask and i want to encourage everyone
watching they can go on the message
boards on facebook or youtube wherever
they're watching this and they can ask
questions that hopefully will be able to
surface uh to alisa uh but also just to
get everyone on the same page
explain to everyone watching what the
focus of teach for america is uh i i
think most people have heard of it it's
one of the non-profits that i've always
looked up to when i started khan academy
but but you you tell me in your own
words what is teach america
well our focus is um working alongside
many partners to take on educational
inequity at the highest level right so
what we know for sure at teach for
america is that potential is distributed
equally across all lines of difference
but the opportunity and the access to
meet that potential does not exist with
all kids in all communities in our
country and you know long before coven
our system was not serving many kids
well enough and so um i think that's
really important for folks to understand
and just to ground folks in that you
know when you look at our lowest income
communities who are disproportionately
children of color about 50 of kids are
graduating from high school and that's
compared to 96 of kids in the most
affluent communities and of those kids
graduating from high school about six
percent make it to and through college
and teach for america exists to say
that is not okay and are committed to
creating a different reality and so we
know that the problem is systemic and
there needs to be change within and
outside of education to really lead to a
different reality we know many
interventions are are needed in order to
be able to take this on and our
contribution is leadership so we go out
and we recruit
support and develop you know exceptional
equity oriented
leaders who teach for at least two years
in urban and rural america they're
expected to you know ensure that our
kids get the education they deserve and
through that are able to get this
clarity of conviction and understanding
of the system the possibility of it the
greatness of our children and become
lifelong advocates and to adjacent
education we've been around for 30 years
we're now 65 000 strong core members and
alumni and our folks 8 and 10 of our of
our folks in our alumni network work
within education or have a career
serving a low-income community which is
incredible because most folks that
joined us had no intention of taking on
this career
no i you know just give people
perspective you know when you go to in
education circles people who are leading
change either directly or even now they
work in industry but on the
philanthropic side or on the policy side
you meet teach for america alumni
everywhere so y'all have been definitely
the alumni the leadership is happening
and how does that happen is
you're recruiting students coming
primarily out of college and graduate
schools uh with a you know for any any
young people listening either high
school students or college students how
do they become part of this teach for
america core
yeah our mandate is to go out and say
you know get young people 75 of our core
are right out of college and so we're
just trying to get people to see
this is amongst the greatest injustice
of our time there's no way for a country
to thrive um to be able to ensure that
everyone can fully contribute without
ensuring that every child has access to
an excellent and equitable education
and to take that on and this young
generation really understands the nature
of the systemic problem you know we find
that folks have on their mind the need
to take on climate change income
inequality
unemployment you know systemic racism
and there's many ways to take that on
and one thing that we try to say is like
ground zero for all these inequities are
honestly in the classroom because you
get to see how all the systems in a
community collide and end up you know
because our kids don't live in vacuums
and all of that ends up in the classroom
and you start to see how you have to you
know of course hold our kids to the
highest expectations and also provide
all the supports all the unmet needs
that kids come with to school and then
you're able to see like things can be
different our kids can do anything um
and we just have to be able to figure
out how do these systems interact
together what can we do about them and
and work in in coalitions and powerful
coalitions
and common things done for kids and so
we're out on college campuses looking
for exceptional folks who demonstrate
leadership um and are up for you know
one of the greatest leadership um you
know challenges ever i will say
even as ceo my hardest job was right out
of college which was being a tfa corps
member in 1998 in phoenix arizona
because it's like the best preparation
to be a ceo i will say
i i i can only i can only imagine you
know what is fast forwarding to today
you know especially we're in
i am curious
we started to talk before we started uh
going live but how has coveted impacted
teach for america on all directions you
know what's what's going on with your
existing teacher core who were in
classroom but now i'm guessing doing
primarily distance learning how is that
affecting your pipeline of finding
future leaders
yeah
so you know we're in the moment as we
all know the greatest disruption in in
education in us history um recent
history certainly and you know for us we
right away so i talked about we have
this network of you know 65 000
folks we right away knew that you know
we we centered on how we were gonna meet
the moment and so we're able to get our
community our network you know learning
together we created an educator resource
up to share best practices right away we
had a platform where our core members
and alumni were able to
you know um put forth projects that they
were trying to fund to just meet the
basic needs for kids or things that were
most pressing in our communities and so
we're able to do that but for us very
practically the first big pivot we had
to make was our summer training and so
in march when we realized that we
weren't going to be able to run summer
school programs which is a main
component of how we train our teachers
we had to figure out if we were even
going to be able to bring in a core um
because we were going to have to train
them in a fundamental a fundamentally
different way and so when we went out
and asked our principals and
superintendents you know do you want
our teachers even though they haven't
you know taught kids which is core to
our model
you know we got a resounding yes now
more than ever we need your teachers and
so
we pulled together just our incredible
staff you know from national teams
regional teams to design we we have our
miami-dade you know executive director
run our program um to design a new
training curriculum in nine weeks we
executed on that in you know four weeks
and two days um and it was an incredible
endeavor what we saw was our teachers
you know coming together in one network
and feeling you know really the most
prepared we've seen in terms of how we
what what needs we were able to meet um
we spent less money and so we were able
to pivot there um and we saw you know
our core members just rising to the
occasion um the highest retention we've
had also throughout the summer so folks
just so committed um as we like process
the world around us knowing gosh there's
no greater
impact that i you know one can be making
than in the classroom with students and
so it's been quite inspiring to sort of
see
the staff and the network come together
to to meet the moment
yeah there's something powerful about
that you know you like the entire
education world had to quickly go to
virtual instruction which was probably
really good preparation there's a lot of
negatives about it but really good
preparation for the teachers having to
then
enter into a virtual environment right
now you know i'm curious about you on
the training side what do you what do
you all focus on that training and are
there things that you all do in that
training that you wish were part of kind
of the mainstream uh schools of ed what
would you do if you could wave a magic
wand on what happens in all teacher
training in the us or in the world
well there's a few things style that
we've learned over time that just really
matter and so
that one of the first things that's so
relevant to this moment is the power of
relationships and i don't know how that
brings to you as you as you hear that um
but it's been really that that that is
so critical in this very moment um you
know our stats are showing or the stats
uh that folks are sharing is that we
have about three million kids that
haven't engaged in learning over you
know since march um either they don't
have devices that about 17 million do
not have connectivity or devices which
is you know like something we just
deeply need to take on um but we know
that the only way to engage kids and and
families um to into is learning is
relationships and so that's a big
component of just like what does it mean
to you know to to be able to build the
trust and i believe change only happens
as fast because there is trust and deep
relationships and so that is a component
of what we do we of course also focus on
you know
rigorous content and we were able to
ensure that all of our core members got
some training
on you know
the science of reading and we know that
this is just so critical i think every
teacher at school needs to ensure that
all teachers get access to this we do
you know um training around
computational thinking as we think about
21st century you know preparedness um
and the fact that 65 of kids in grade
school today are gonna
you know seek out jobs that we don't
even know what they are today uh is so
critical and so how were we developing
those critical thinking skills and um
and and the social emotional skills that
are are needed we also teach in a
trauma-informed way and so that's core
to the training that we are able to
provide to our teachers and the support
um and especially in this moment when
our kids are in the middle of
experiencing severe loss
fear and um and so much uncertainty
we've got to ensure that we're really
able to meet the basic needs for kids
the human needs um and and then be able
to support them so that academically
we're not leaving an entire generation
behind which is what so many people
are talking about and that's still a
choice to be made then of course
we have an entire focus on
racial equity and ensuring that our
teachers um are culturally competent
teachers and able to to support our kids
in a way that's most responsible that
leads to the most learning and
engagement overall
no that makes makes makes a ton of sense
you know having questions come in on
social media from facebook livy
valenzuela asks do you believe children
will be behind once we return to actual
physical school
what can i do as a parent
um you know what i mean i i know you're
familiar sal with all the studies coming
out from nwea mckinsey so many folks who
are analyzing the situation
and the truth of the matter is that
without question
kids on average are going to be behind
and especially
children growing up in low income
communities who are just partially kids
of color who were already likely behind
on average coming into schools
um the fact that as i said earlier 17
million kids still don't have access to
devices um and and connectivity um and
that's only part of it as i i know you
have said sal that like technology for
technology's sake is not the point once
you even then have the technology we
then have to ensure that we are you know
developing our teachers on how to then
teach with this and ensure that that is
in place so our kids are able to
engage um and so i do believe that you
know every indicator is telling us that
our kids are going to be grossly behind
and so the things i think we've got to
be focused on
is number one ensuring that everyone
truly does have access to a device and
connectivity because this isn't about
this pandemic this is about the future
this is just a tool that every kids
needs it is the basics like paper and
pencils we talked about everyone needs a
backpack a paper and a start school
everyone needs access to a device and
connectivity moving forward for us to
continue to find the path forward to
best educate all kids
and we've got to train our teachers on
that um also we've got to ensure that we
have
information about what our kids need you
know
there's a lot of questions right now
about testing and should we be testing
our kids or not and it's like it's often
tied to accountability
and this is a moment to you know
reimagine how we think about testing and
accountability for this year what i feel
strongly about as imperfect as tests are
we really need to know where are our
kids so that we can appropriately
intervene so that we can be smart
about about our investments
in ensuring that kids get what they need
and then the last thing i'll say is we
need to make sure that we are advocating
for for dollars for funding um during
the last great recession
we
invested a lot more than we have in this
moment through this crisis right now we
have seen five times less funding coming
into schools with a much greater
challenge with many complexities so not
only do we need to meet the basic needs
of kids right i'm watching educators in
schools right out of you know after the
pandemic figure out how are we going to
feed our kids we fight we're realizing
schools feed kids
schools provide all these social you
know um like social nets for kids that
suddenly are gone safety
access to a clinic etc and so right away
our educators have been focused on
meeting those those needs um and we're
gonna have to continue to do that and
the trauma-informed teaching um but also
you know the academics and and be smart
about that and be ensure that it's it's
personalized and that we're really um
ensuring that parents and
their families and kids are and teachers
educators are able to work together um
to figure out how to close those gaps so
as a parent i would just be asking
questions about um how do we know where
our kids are and where investments need
to go and do we have the investments
needed to
ensure that we're able to
educate all kids and invest in our
greatest natural resource we have in
this country which is our students
absolutely and just to add olivier to
lisa's
response which i 100 agree with
you know above and beyond everything
that the schools are doing when you ask
what you can do as a parent you know my
my advice there is i don't know how well
your your children are
but to at least point there's ways that
you can evaluate where your kids are uh
you can go to khan academy especially in
math and science and
other areas
but you can use what we call our get
ready for grade level courses they have
something called a course challenge in
it and let's say you have a child who's
i'm making it up
uh entering sixth grade or just entered
sixth grade a few months ago you can do
the get ready for sixth grade
course challenge if they score 80 90 on
it that means they don't have any
significant gaps from pre-sixth grade
and then i would recommend them working
at their own time and pace 20 to 40
minutes a day in math
uh in personalized practice going
through and trying to get mastery in all
of sixth grade on khan academy uh and if
they are having trouble in the get ready
for sixth grade they can go and look at
the units or you can work with them to
look at the units where they have
trouble and then they should get
mastering those gaps and then they can
go on to the sixth grade work uh i i
feel confident if they do that 20 30 40
minutes a day over the course of the
school year and beyond they're going to
do just fine they might even accelerate
their learning on the english and
language arts side
there's tools khan academy you can use
there's uh there's there's four paid
tools that are are pretty good too like
lexia or as kids once again you can do
20 30 minutes a day but it could often
be as simple as you know asking them to
read a magazine article depending on
their age read it you know read it and
then we'll discuss it at lunch if you
create those kind of habits over the
course of the year and then you know the
writing just make sure they don't
atrophy that skill say hey once a week i
want you to write
something that you want to change at
home
you know change your bedtime something
want to change in the world we'll
discuss it that's going to that's going
to make sure they don't atrophy but
those are just some some things you can
make sure if your kids do fine just in
your household i have no doubt that
they're not going to fall behind it's
still going to be sub-optimal but they
won't fall behind
yes yes
there's a question there's a question
here from facebook laura jones uh even
students who are straight a honor
students are failing how do we help them
recover from this even with devices kids
are struggling and alisa i'll add to
that question
what are you all telling you know what
are your teachers seeing and what are
you telling them for this you know
there's a teacher who lives in my
cul-de-sac who has you know i live in a
middle class upper middle class
neighborhood where
she also is seeing five ten percent of
her kids are completely disengaged right
now
how are y'all coaching the teaching
corps to re-engage or keep these kids
engaged and prevent the situation that
laura is talking about of a former
straight a student now failing classes
yeah
this is such an important question
sal and there's there's a few things
that come to mind
one is um that we haven't hit on yet is
i i observe that um a lot of our the way
we're trying to approach virtual
teaching is the way we approached you
know being in school
which really is not working for kids i
mean there's just enough data and
information that we have and if we
should just go talk to our kids i mean
parents talk to their kids every day and
you often hear
it's boring i don't understand the point
of it it just feels so irrelevant and
not not pressing and so this is an
opportunity and you know where tfa we
talk about like the need for radical
reimagination this is a time for
creativity this is time to say that
isn't working what is relevant to our
kids like this the work kids should be
doing
should be in context of what's happening
in the world right now there's so much
happening in the world right now that's
helping to build their own
you know their their knowledge and
skills i read something on the 74
million um and they're doing these
letters
student letters to adults saying
hello here's what we need and want and
examples like get kids to you know in
your economics class to actually go
figure out how are you going to save the
business that is going out of you know
that that is doesn't have the
because of covet and the shutdown of the
economy is deeply struggling like what
are the solutions to that and what would
you do and you know what would you tell
the mayor or the governor and and just
like real world context um that we can
actually really grab onto um and figure
out how do we start
ensuring that there's relevance that
one size fits all you know doesn't work
anymore for to meet our kids where they
are
um and i don't think they're gonna show
up unless they can see
that this matters and is interesting and
you know and that they're um they're
actually getting something for it
um the other thing that we observe going
on you know as we talk to our own
teachers
is our kids have a lot going on you know
um our kids now are supporting their own
families they watch you know their
families lose jobs and so you know i i
observe some systems saying you know you
got to show up for these hours and
here's the expectation but it's not in
the context of a global pandemic and the
impacts of what that is having on our
kids their families and their lives and
so we've just got to be more
um in conversation and in relationship
with again families and the students
themselves to really understand their
circumstances to then be able to figure
out you know how do we adapt i'm
watching some of our school leaders get
really present with that and say we
can't expect kids to be in school all
day they're not going to do it they
actually have to go work to support
their family and so instead we're going
to have these hours in the evening um
that seem to work better six to nine or
you know when this is when we're going
to actually host classes and so just the
need to really um figure out how do we
meet people where they are in this
moment and that's what i'm observing of
our um of our network as well there's
this one school in saint louis led by
tfa alums um cairo's academy
and they had technology already i mean
their their whole method was it's year
long it's your round um
school they they do least learning
checks and chunks in seven weeks and so
they have the technology because they're
big on personalized learning
but they know that's just one tool like
the thing they also have is the
relationships and the deep understanding
of how important that is to be able to
execute um and so they were able to
through this pandemic they have pods
there's one adult to 10 kids who are in
a relationship understanding the needs
and that person also liaison to the
families and so there's a constant you
know adapting and ensuring that there's
like you know real understanding in
order to ensure that we're able to keep
kids engaged and their engagement rate
is through the roof and so it takes us
really um thinking about the work
differently and understanding and being
empathetic to what our our kids needs
and really present to that
no i absolutely and you know the only
thing i would add to that is depending
on the age of the student if you're
talking about someone pre-high school
you know grades matter and that they're
a signal and that you don't want to fail
a whole grade and have to repeat it but
the important thing is is that the child
keeps mastering the concepts and as we
mentioned there's tools to do that to
make sure they keep mastering in high
school when the stakes were a little bit
higher in terms of your transcript and
college admissions
i would have a conversation i mean
definitely talk to the child talk to
student but also talk to the school
about it because i think right now
you're seeing people are being you know
they understand that this is a very
weird situation and there should be more
outlets for kids who maybe are failing
or having struggling to eventually be
able to get back on the horse and show
that they know the material but yeah
it's it's a it's a real um
it's a real issue uh let's see one one
more we have time with one more question
this time goes by fast when we're having
fun alyssa um from youtube smart bear
how do we help students re-enter school
i mean like before they were happy to
enter schools because they had friends
and there was no virus but now students
will be filled with fear to enter school
because of the pandemic well i guess it
could be
i think most people aren't thinking
about seriously re-entering schools
until at earliest the the spring and
maybe next school year but i think even
then the question is is relevant people
might not be afraid of the virus then
but
friendships might have been broken all
sorts of learning gaps they're not even
used to the pattern of waking up and
getting ready and getting on the school
bus how do you think that's going to
play out what should we do
well you know sal this is where i go
back to like my hope is that we don't
just say everyone should go back to
school and be doing school in the same
way right because there are a segment of
kids who are thriving in in this in this
environment who actually don't like the
social and get intimidated and you know
and are are able to just sort of clear
the air and really thrive in in this
environment and my question is why can't
that continue to be true and also um
figure out how we can be doing schools
and getting kids back with each other we
we do have enough research that shows
that you know the the social development
part of this is really important
especially for the younger kids um in
being back at school i mean my kids have
been i have four sons and they've been
back in school now for nearly 11 weeks
and um and they've they they love going
to school um and they go to a montessori
school and they have really loved the
opportunity to go back it's smaller
schools it's smaller class sizes and you
know they're able to you know it's been
interesting to watch my kids thrive um
in the environment that's a bit
different than what it was before but i
think we just have to really be in
communication with our kids and
hopefully thinking creatively of how do
we do school now that it got interrupted
like what did work about that for you
know some kids what did it work about
that um and how do we really
listen to students and families and
communities you know um i think
solutions are within the community and
we often don't spend enough time really
understanding that to then inform our
approach which i just think is so key to
being able to do this well
yeah well no well you know there's so
much we could continue to con talk about
alyssa as i said teach for america's i
think one of the not-for-profits that i
always cite you know honestly one of the
reasons why i even thought khan academy
could be a not-for-profit i was like
well look here's a not-for-profit that
is in education they've been able to
scale able to have incredible impact and
so uh you know i've always looked up to
the work that y'all do and i think what
we're doing is very complementary uh in
terms of you know y'all are working on
kind of the human capital that really is
is so key in
reaching students and the leadership and
we're working on the tools and the
content to help support both those
teachers and the kids they serve and the
families so uh it's been a pleasure to
chat with you and i hope we can we can
keep this conversation going in on on
future future days both both on a live
stream and not
yes you got it thank you so much sal
be well happy holiday you too
happy holidays well thanks everyone for
joining thanks for joining uh today's
session of live stream uh hopefully
you'll be able to join us tomorrow we're
gonna have dr jarrett bryant assistant
superintendent of houston independent
school district and what we're learning
about post-secondary success so once
kids get to college and whatever else so
i will see you then and until then have
a good uh evening or morning or wherever
you are in the world i'll hopefully see
you tomorrow
you